well well well oh herb street believes
players should serve their time not so
fast my friend no please you're going
against conventional draft wisdom make
like me in the preseason drop them
hop on the bandwagon it's crowded now
what's good bro hey joe oh hello
pleasure
[Music]
so i said to them if the titans are a
one scene i'd hate to see what 7c is the
bengals have officially arrived can't
have a party without uno chase of a
cincinnati kid sorry we don't normally
let ohio teams make the playoffs in
back-to-back years i can win the
shootout i'm an actual cowboy we're a
defensive team now wait that's the man
who beat us we used to be the fun team
not our
time to mix it up and run
nobody wait this is cincinnati i feel
like the bengals stole the whole thing
taste some just drive today zack snack
more chilly we're here to read
and i swear we're open to a tie what you
think you know i've eaten a lot of chili
so it's time to air it out
are they posing yeah they're cruel i'm
circling the wagon
[Music]
will uno chase and the cincinnati kid
collapse to the playoffs like the
bengals of old did gridiron heights just
curse cincinnati like they did the 2018
mayors the 2019 mills and the 2020 bears
and will zach taylor make enough food
for his hungry lads find out next week
on gridiron heights